special thanks to squarespace for
sponsoring this video stick around for
later to hear more about squarespace
to set the stage the year is
1990-something
spider-man hasn't had a substantial
cartoon on the network in quite a while
marvel is facing bankruptcy from some
bad investments and sketchy business
decisions
they begin selling off their rights to
various movie studios and hollywood
giant james cameron was interested in
adapting spider-man to the big screen
with a movie featuring electro sandman
and a lot of awkward outdoor public sex
scenes with mary jane uh spidey says the
f word to coincide with the upcoming
movie that we now know never came to
pass fox kids was tasked with bringing
spider-man to television in a brand new
way that broke the mold with possible
connections to the already immensely
popular x-men series that had just
launched shortly before
put yourself in the shoes of
screenwriter and animation producer john
semper jr the man behind the water
slaughter he's got a fair amount of
experience creating and running animated
television shows he's a massive
spider-man fan he knows the character
inside and out and he's already
established a friendship with the one
and only co-creator of spider-man stan
lee naturally he seems like the perfect
choice for
well actually he was the second choice
after the first show runner got fired
well that was lucky because semper came
onto the series wanting to do something
that had never been done before with
spider-man and did he succeed oh
definitely spider-man the animated
series brought spider-man to life by
combining depth-full operatic character
drama multi-part complex serialized
story arcs faithful and appreciative
adaptations of the source material and
of course morbius's scary plasma sucker
hands
this is easily one of my favorite
animated shows of all time let's dive
deep and talk about why
from the look of the series reimagining
spider-man's mythos with more 90s
appropriate redesigns of the main cast
to featuring recent characters like
carnage venom and hobgoblin to the
show's blend of cgi and cell animation
spider-man the animated series is very
obviously a product of its time
the comics of that era were all turned
around about clones so many look to this
show as the new way to get their fix for
serialized spidey story arcs whenever i
think of this show i'm always reminded
of the color palette and visuals of the
scenes at night this spidey just looks
wrong during the daytime somehow all of
the most important scenes took place in
the darkened new york skyline
highlighted by bright yellow windows on
the skyscrapers surrounding them bad
guys with giant toyetic armor and
machines bearing down on spider-man with
laser rifles in hand there's just
nothing quite like it so this show's
look is very special to me but on top of
that it goes for a really strong sense
of realism to the designs everything is
mechanical and detailed and designed
with intended purpose and function
this was a nice contrast to the heavy
stylized approach from the warner
brothers batman series of time with a
more gothic noir look
and you know it translated well to toys
spider-man the animated series also
dabbled in 3d animation to give us some
really dynamic sweeping backgrounds and
crazy shifting perspectives for
spider-man swinging scenes that just
couldn't be obtained with static painted
backgrounds it may look dated by today's
standards but they were pioneering a
mixed media method that's incredibly
common in modern cartoons
almost to a detriment because no one
wants to draw cars anymore they're all
3d models
this outside the box approach the
visuals for the action was really
creative and unique back then
the characters themselves all have a
look that's very distinct and easily
associated with this show like peter
parker's 70s haircut that stanley
insisted was more hip and modern than
the early concept art even though it was
the 90s or how everyone had those
charmingly high-waisted denim jeans when
i got there they they uh had designed
peter to look pretty much the way that
he looked in the uh the johnny ramita
comic books we drew peter we initially
had peter looking exactly as he looked
in those comic books bob richardson sent
me this picture he
i think he faxed it to me and he said
this is what peter looks like now
when i first saw it i didn't like it
because it wasn't the peter parker that
i had grown up with it was stan you know
one day stan just
woke up on the wrong side of the bed i
guess would be the best expression and
he just decided that this peter parker
that we had been working with looked
old-fashioned and he wanted something
that looked you know younger and hipper
or
his idea of what younger and hipper
looked like
i also love that this peter parker is
the most jacked buff bulky manly slab of
hunk you've ever seen and people still
don't really think he might be a
superhero
maybe the haircut was distracting from
his 24 inch biceps like clark kent
glasses while the x-men broke ground by
having every episode bleed into the next
or show remnants of those before it
spider-man took it a step further by
finding the unique middle ground of
self-contained story arcs that span
multiple episodes john semper knew that
james cameron's theatrical spidey was in
the works even though it eventually
deservedly crashed and burned and
decided to counter that by trading the
story of spider-man like a series of
movies broken up in half hour segments
some long some short sometimes the story
wrapped up within 30 minutes too it all
depended on what was appropriate for the
story they wanted to tell it almost
feels like hopping back and forth
between spidey's ongoings at the time
like web of spider-man spectacular and
amazing season one consisted mostly of
one-offs to get the characters and
setting established and had a fair
amount of influence from official marvel
writers such as gary conway marv wolfman
and stanley himself making adjustments
to the scripts after long enough the
majority of the writing duties fell to
jon semper himself with a handful of
writers backing him up following his
guidelines for the plot
though pretty much all the scripts were
written or heavily rewritten by him i
like to think of it as this show is
pretty much his own sort of spidey comic
run because very rarely does a show of
this length have pretty much one major
creative voice behind the writing for
that long uninterrupted and many of
semper's ideas for the show ended up
becoming so heavily associated with
spidey that they're often falsely
attributed to being part of the comic
history
either that or his influence impacted
pretty much all adaptations of
spider-man going forward because he did
such a magnificent job of remixing
simplifying or tying ideas together from
the comics that make them feel like one
coherent creative voice instead of a
rotating team of writers across many
decades
many of the creative choices in
spider-man tas that differentiate it
from other spidey takes from before it
have become really common ideas being
used even to this day like giving dr
octavius a role inspiring peter's love
of science and being a teacher slash
mentor for him before becoming a villain
[Music]
is meaningless
the important thing it justifies all
that we do in its service in the books
they had no prior relationship or
knowledge of each other but that little
change makes otto a slightly more tragic
villain there's also the change to the
venom symbiote in this series it turns
peter into an aggressive violent monster
that nearly kills someone until he has
to force it off himself
this change carried on into the ultimate
comics the movies a few of the games and
even the later cartoons but originally
the symbiote didn't affect spider-man's
behavior at all
it started making him exhausted every
morning but his personality remained the
same it just kept taking his body for
joy rides while he was asleep at night
because it just like jumping around
pumping adrenaline fighting crime and
kissing black cat that change to turn
the symbiote more villainous made sense
for why eddie brock would become such a
psycho when he first bonded with it and
also make peter seem like less of a jerk
for ditching the suit so quickly without
fully understanding it
we also have dr connors being a science
teacher at peter's college for the first
time which carried on into the movies
other cartoons games and eventually the
mainline comics this was the first
appearance of man spider which ended up
being a popular enough idea that the
comics used it many years later during
the paul jenkins run
and it's kind of a skin in one of the
games
mary jane being the first major love
interest was a new idea and the scene of
goblin taking her up onto the bridge to
throw her off made it into the sam raimi
films in the brian michael bendis comics
they eventually introduced madame webb
in the series who in this continuity
isn't just clairvoyant she has
interdimensional powers that can warp
reality and see through time and space
which she uses to assemble a squad of
spider-men from various realities to
save the day across the multiverse a
plot re-used later in shattered
dimensions hell this show might even be
the reason why everyone thought the
hobgoblin was jason mcindale and no one
even remembers roger kingsley but that's
also roger kingsley's fault for using
like 40 decoys
even deadpool was one of the hobgoblin
decoys it got so crazy but now everyone
just thinks hobgoblin is the ceo of sex
one of my favorite things about
spider-man is his homemade and yet
really detailed and badass costume
i haven't been into spidey cosplay as
much lately so i thought i'd shout out a
young creator that consistently blows me
away with his projects and creativity
check out kmc design studios on youtube
and instagram this kid is always doing
some of the most unique spidey cosplays
i've ever seen from puff painting the
entire costume top to bottom to look
super movie accurate to the amazing
spider-man to using elastic for the
webbing i think he just started taking
cosplay commission so go show him some
love and maybe buy one of his cool
designs
there were so many ideas in this show
that were completely original and yet
they've become so synonymous with the
character that they almost work better
than what was originally canon to the
source material
these are good changes and if you
haven't noticed there are a ton of
things that were adapted directly to the
rainy spider-man movies
in fact i would go so far as to say
these movies are more adapting this
cartoon than the comics
look at the amount of parallels lifted
directly from this show
green goblin is an alternate personality
that is getting revenge on the oscorp
board of directors for mistreating
norman osborn the goblin formula and
glider weapons were built by ozcorp for
someone else to use initially norman has
an awkward dinner with peter because he
knows you spider-man goblin drops mary
jane off the bridge kurt connors is
university professor peter fails to make
it to a show mary jane is starring in
otto octavius is peter's science hero
otto was injured while trying to build a
portable reactor that can produce
infinite energy he takes a hostage in
his warehouse on the waterfront where he
attempts to finish that machine harry
flips out and yells at peter at a party
harry discovers peter's identity and
starts being goaded towards revenge by
his father's ghost that keeps pushing
him to become the new goblin and show
him things that harry couldn't possibly
know on his own so it's not a
hallucination it's actually a ghost or
his dad from another universe maybe
eddie brock is peter's rival at the
bugle who he humiliates multiple times
until ruining his career for trying to
frame spider-man for a crime introducing
gwen stacy way later in the story the
venom symbiote gets to earth through a
meteorite peter getting the black suit
almost shot for shot the exact same
scene a few of these are like that
honestly peter attempts to kill a super
villain because the suit has corrupted
his mind he takes it to dr connors to
examine a sample of it instead of the
fantastic four the suit drips directly
off peter and on to eddie at the bottom
of the bell tower sam raimi and the men
behind the scripts for these movies
clearly loved this cartoon i feel like
it should get more credit for pioneering
so many different takes on spidey's home
life and his relationships with his
villains spider-man the animated series
was definitely a strong creative effort
on the part of the writers but part of
that was because there were limitations
placed on what the series could and
could not do
as well as making the producers happy
with some of the strange ideas a fair
amount of the show was also driven by of
course action figures this series was an
action figure factory like none before
but what i think sets it apart once
again is that the creators tried their
best to make sure the costumes and
objects from the toy line made sense in
the show
leading to the original spider-verse
trying to cover some of these alternate
costumes in a reasonable way
one of the more famous and weirder
tidbits of this show is that hobgoblin
appears before the green goblin
because the previous show runner had
decided that hobgoblin would be a major
character and the toy line already had
him coming up in the first set so semper
and the creators had to come up with a
logical reason for him to appear first
and settled on him basically being some
goon that tests out norman's weapons and
goblin gimmick before he commits to
doing it himself and far better look at
this toyatic monstrosity his glider is
giant and purple and plugs into an even
bigger and gianter purple glider now
that's an action figure
every once in a while while watching
this show with my friends we would see a
certain design and we would just shout
audibly out loud
now that's an action figure but toy
sales weren't the only driving
limitation with the show
they were also subject to heavy
censorship
just like every cartoon at this time
and today
i i did not get notes any different from
anyone else making
animation for children
then
and probably now
nothing changes and i said you know we
couldn't do this and we couldn't do that
and you know be careful that i got a
note once be careful that when
spider-man lands on the roof uh you know
he doesn't harm the pigeons which is a
real note that i did get
what i didn't realize was that one day
somebody was going to compile this as a
list
and put it on a wiki
and it was going to become gospel like
somehow
spider-man had gotten more
censorship than any other cartoon show
in the history of mankind there was
enough fighting going on in my own home
base
that i really didn't feel like fighting
with broadcast standards and practices i
argued once for the use of a real gun
because i thought it was integral to the
story that was when robbie robertson
his son was
in a gang and he turned out that the
gang was being run by tombstone and i
went to the
bsnp person and said i want this to be a
recognizable gun and
she gave in because i really had not
caused any huge amount of trouble for
you know other things
for the record we got no different
treatment
than anyone else on saturday morning
we got
nothing that i wasn't already used to in
fact we probably got away with way more
than i expected that we would get away
with they all had the same amount of
censorship except maybe batman because
it was one of the first shows on the
network so they got more leeway this
series had the same rules as x-men in
later seasons of batman and gargoyles
and any animated show on television
today it's become a really common
misconception that this show was hit
with network-mandated censorship
especially hard
but it really just came down to jon
semper jr and other writers wanting to
play it more safe they didn't believe
that they needed spider-man punching his
villains constantly or characters firing
guns or characters dying
because if they used these things
sparingly it was more impactful when
they did actually happen real guns do
appear in the show spider-man does hit
people and eventually this show has some
more gut-wrenching death scenes and
cartoons that really traumatized some
kids spider-man tas could do all the
things x-men the animated series could
but just chose not to for safety and
honestly i barely noticed as a kid that
spidey wasn't throwing a lot of punches
he's still grappling with people webbing
them up kicking them and throwing things
at them so the fight choreography isn't
non-existent or anything it often gets
irritating for me hearing how people
make this the only talking point about
the show because they're operating off
the misinformation that this series was
somehow targeted harshly for content
censorship when it really wasn't
and in spite of this cautious approach
to its content the show still had
well-written and interesting character
drama for peter parker's life in many
trials i you know i've come across this
comment online and it infuriates me
someone will go
well i like that spider-man show but i
have a problem with all that censorship
all that censorship just ruins it for me
it's it's the show is doomed
and fatally flawed by all that
censorship well that's just [ __ ] i
mean it's no different
than the same broadcast standards and
practices of a show that would be on the
air right now
you know for anyone that can look at the
depth of storytelling that we had
and then be bothered by the fact that we
had a laser rifle instead of an uzi
i don't understand that that's just
silly to me but the fact of the matter
is plot wise it doesn't change anything
it really doesn't
because
the key to good plotting is character
interaction and suspense and conflict
and you can have all of those things
without having to have
people bleeding people puking and people
dying i mean
none of those other three things that i
just mentioned are integral to great
dramatic storytelling personally i felt
no limitation whatsoever none whatsoever
i got to tell the stories that i wanted
to tell that's really all i have to say
on the subject of the show censorship
because there's nothing else to say
about it and this show is interesting in
so many other ways than that like the
fact that venom is voiced by hanka's
area all right here's the 4-1-1 folks
say some gangster is pissing the fly
girl
just give money
there's an impressive amount of voice
talent backing the show legends like the
great ed asner as j jonah jameson
jennifer hale as felicia hardy slash
black cat the occasional appearance of
rob paulson's hydro man and mark hamill
as hobgoblin and the aforementioned mo
syslag is eddie brock not to mention the
star of the show himself christopher
daniel barnes most well known before
this for playing prince eric and the
little mermaid barnes grew up collecting
comic books and was given the chance to
live out childhood fantasy and bringing
the earnest peter parker to life during
the course of the five seasons being
around the same age as this incarnation
of spider-man he feels completely
natural and in his element as this
character i believe his ability and love
for the source material was integral to
bringing a sense of believability to the
role and he plays the character with a
level of respect and love that can
clearly be heard with his performance do
you take me for a fool who amongst you
has ever wanted to give up their
superpowers i have because i've learned
time and time again that with great
power there must also come great
responsibility also this doc ock is the
one i hear when i read the comics so i
imagined all of superior spider-man with
peter randomly talking in a german
accent no one noticing
speaking of this is a great take on
peter parker it really makes you feel
like
this is definitely the series greatest
strength we follow him across the course
of the series and we experience all his
highs and lows with him whether he's
just trying to earn some extra money by
getting a shot of a new super villain
for the paper or volunteering as a
teacher at a science foundation or
experiencing the greatest hardships back
to back we even get a sense of him
maturing and coming of age even without
him starting the show in high school he
certainly has his lows though
like straight up pitfalls this spidey
gets dumped on
getting put through the ringer so often
has him wanting to quit being a
superhero at least once a season but he
never falls into feeling like a complete
train wreck of a human being to the
point of self-parody nor is he like a
netflix marvel superhero where he's
gotta quit every mid-season and be like
ah go throw his costume away i can't
wear this no more i'm gonna spend a
whole episode just soul-searching and
being being feeling sad for myself the
love behind this project ended up
producing one of the most accurate
representations of the character we've
ever seen as much as i've clearly gushed
over the show it's not without its flaws
some story lines get a little too long
and start to really drag in the middle
as much as i like blade and punisher
showing up i feel that some of the stuff
with morbius got a bit tedious because
so much time was devoted to it i don't
particularly like that character
and it pains me to say this but i was so
bored by the six forgotten warriors arc
we're like six forgettable warriors
on every re-watch now i just skipped to
the hydro simp again and get the ball
rolling on the final arc it was an
attempt at building up a way to
introduce captain america into the
marvel animated universe through a
spider-man story but i could care less
about all the older superheroes spidey
bumps into along the way and i think
having red skull sun become electro was
unexpected but also a little weird i
mentioned earlier that electro and
sandman were slated to be in the james
cameron movie so they weren't allowed to
be used for this series when the movie
fell apart and never released semper
decided to toss electro in here as a big
bad and elected to not use sandman
because he was already content using
hydro man in about the same role this
series also hit a lot of rough deadlines
so there's some jagged edges on the
animation here and there like errors
reused footage or certain scenes looking
a bit stiff they didn't quite have the
animation budget from x-men which is
reflected in how the character shading
is more simplified and they couldn't
polish the timing for the show as much
with editing this show feels really
spastically edited because like there's
always music blaring at full volume in
the background and everything moves so
fast i do think that this show visually
cleans up better for digital releases
better than all the other shows for some
reason
it just looks nicer on a modern tv than
x-men the linework is more crisp and the
color palette is more pretty on modern
devices i can't really put my finger on
why it could be that the traditional
parts of the show would have been
digitized back then in order to combine
it all with the cg elements that make up
the backgrounds but that's really just a
guess on my part i also wish this spidey
was allowed more appearances in other
shows from the classic marvel animated
universe i mean he was the unofficial
star of marvel team up before they
decided they couldn't live the lie any
longer and just retitled the book to
spider-man team up
but semper was a bit protective of this
spidey and didn't want him being used in
a place where he wasn't in total control
of how the character was utilized
so spider-man couldn't show up in x-men
fantastic four iron man or hulk beyond
small cameos in each however everyone
else was totally allowed to jump into
this show whenever we have a big
two-part team up with the 90s x-men iron
man and war machine helping battle venom
and carnage and the fantastic four show
up in the secret wars arc this show also
has the same daredevil that hangs out
with fantastic four in their own show
and hydro man even fights them once
there's enough there in the way of a
shared connection to say that yeah sure
these shows are all definitely in the
same universe but i think it would have
been more fun to have spidey be a
full-on guest character in the other
shows as well
as mentioned mary jane was the main love
interest in this show and they decided
to not use gwen stacy for so much of it
because they wanted to avoid having to
show her death
but the decision was made to sort of
meld her character with felicia hardy
before she became black cat
as for getting rid of mary jane instead
of killing her off the show decided to
use portals to other dimensions as a way
to semi-permanently dispatched
characters they wanted to kill off so it
makes sense why they stopped appearing
without shutting down the possibility of
them coming back entirely and without
scarring small children by
showing cletus cassidy getting his head
bitten off or something this opened up
the portal door to a whole host of wacky
stories with characters using portals to
go to other dimensions which ended up
really bolstering the show's final
season the main through line of this
series is the wise old woman who can see
through time and space named madame webb
watching spider-man take on various
tests of his will and character to see
if he's the right person to stop some
kind of impending doom that will wipe
out all of the entire multiverse
like infinite trillions of deaths
simultaneously on the horizon she jumps
into his life every couple of days or
weeks to tell him he's about to
encounter something rough and encourages
him to make the right choice without
telling him what to do outright and even
though he's a grouchy jerk that wants to
quit being spider-man constantly he ends
up always making the right choice anyway
making this particular spider-man
special
finally at the end of this series after
losing mary jane to who knows where
forever losing his best friend and being
put through the ringer in a bunch of
really messed up ways and then being
tossed into a pretty cool adaptation of
secret wars he's finally called upon for
his final battle
[Music]
he's gotta fight another spider-man
madame webb tells peter he has to lead
the charge of various multiversal
versions of himself to save all of time
and space from another spider-man who
went insane with grief and bonded to the
carnage symbiote to become a ruthless
genocidal dictator that's planning to
use the dimensional portal technology to
kill everyone everywhere ever the reason
our spidey is so special is because he
didn't lose himself in his grief like
spider carnage he overcame a lot of
challenges that came with getting his
powers was almost permanently mutated
into a monster by them he proved he was
ready to lead another group of
superheroes during secret wars and he
was humbled by so many bad things
happening to him that he didn't end up
being an arrogant jerk like the
spider-man and the old trusty spidey
armor it's not just being peter parker
that makes him special it's being this
peter parker
shaped and molded by all of his
experiences into a stronger leader and
really powerful force for good pretty
much everything leads up to this final
moment and i won't spoil how he chooses
to save the day from his evil
doppelganger because it's a really great
moment and even gets a bit shockingly
dark afterwards too if you haven't seen
it i think it's worth it to watch this
show just for the main overarching story
that builds up to this big finale arc
because it's a great payoff to spidey's
hero's journey in a way that sets him
apart from a lot of spider-man
interpretations at the end
there's just one little loose end that
never got quite resolved
where's mary jane
the show ends with madame webb saying
she's still live somewhere in the
multiverse and she's going to help peter
find mj finally
but it was cancelled by the network
before we could see that happen
over the years john semper has made it
clear that he had a fair amount of ideas
in place for that sixth season
like finding mj in a victorian london
version of the marvel universe where
carnage was jack the ripper at
conventions he used to hand out a script
he whipped up for what that could have
looked like
and even had the cast read some portions
of it for a panel at a convention but
it's a quick and short script that
doesn't feel quite like it would have
been the thing we'd have seen on tv had
the final season been made
and there's still so many characters
left up in the air that the script
doesn't even mention what happened to
green goblin the spot or venom my
friends dane jacob and i were so racked
with grief over the loose threads that
we even made a fan comic trying to use
some of the unmade season 6 ideas as
well as my own take on how you could
fold in some of the lost characters from
the series maybe check it out and tell
me what you think in the comments we're
still working on it because making
comics is hard and takes a while but i
think it's a really fun project and it's
nice telling a story about spidey for
once instead of just talking about them
this show may not have gotten the
perfect official ending but it stopped
at a place that while feeling pretty
satisfying leaving off on peter's
resolving his multi-season character arc
left a lot of us clamoring for more and
excited to dig further into spider-man
as a character
i think this show made super fans out of
a million kids in the 90s and sparked
such a passion for the character in his
world its impact as a more streamlined
take on spidey is completely undeniable
and even 20 plus years later we're still
using some of its ideas in modern
adaptations this series shows why
sometimes it's okay to stray from the
source material if it's in service of
bolstering the best moments and ideas
from it but also gives us some of the
best examples of following that material
really closely too with some great
adaptations of classic comic stories if
you're looking to get into spider-man
but feel intimidated by the sheer amount
of comics this series is a safe bet
because it adapts the broad strokes
really well while also compiling the
more messy parts into a simple form
the clone saga in this show is a
lot more simple than
all that
spider-man the animated series is a
really unique piece of history with the
character because very rarely do you get
an adaptation of such a major character
with so few cooks in the kitchen and
that nearly singular creative voice
really helped narrow it all down into a
really well told series
that reimagines him but also still truly
understands the heart of spider-man's
core
while also trying to stay positive and
hopeful
i'd be a down and out broken depressed
spidey too if not for sponsors like
squarespace
squarespace gives you a user-friendly
and beautiful platform to maintain and
run your very own website you can
connect with your site's users through
gated members only content as well as
sending email notifications leverage
audience insights all on one easy to use
platform you can create your own
community with comment sections with
threaded comments and likes
these handy blogging tools built in can
help you easily categorize and share
posts on the site you can get even more
from squarespace with third-party
extensions to manage inventory promote
products streamline bookkeeping or
whatever else your site needs to run
like a well-oiled machine and you can
even display posts from your social
media on your site to make sure your
followers are connected and can share
them too go to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash this special code to save 10
percent off your first purchase for a
website or domain
[Music]
you